automatic editing for video podcasts and
shows and the goal is to Save hours in
your weekly production time in Adobe
Premiere with their pack of plugins I
think it was Omar El takori who first
showed me this tool when he was editing
a multi-angle video shoot that was an
interviewer a conversation among
multiple people when you shoot a video
like that you end up throwing all four
of those angles into a Premiere timeline
and then you go through the tedious
process of choosing who to cut to when
to cut to them and if it was a hour-long
conversation the edit could take at
least an hour if not two or three enter
autopod you simply install the plugin
click go basically and in a matter of
minutes or even seconds it edits through
the entire multi-camera shoot knowing
who's talking when they're talking and
picking out all of the shots for you
literally it turns three hours of
editing into three minutes now of course
it's always a good idea to review to
watch it back maybe watch it back at one
and a half or 2x speed just to see if
there was any edits you want to change
or any differences that you want to make
but there's no doubt about it this is a
real Time Saver now autopod also has a
social clip Creator a very easy to use
tool that allows you to just create
Clips out of different parts of your
video right from the Premiere Pro
timeline now what's cool about this is
it'll help you create the different
resolutions very easily do you want to
make a square clip do you want to make
it vertical do you want it 1080p do you
want it 4K and then finally it also has
a jump cut editor so you can actually
input the decibel cut off of your
particular microphone and create cuts
and so the use case of this would be if
you shoot a video like I'm doing right
now a talking head video that ends up
being like one 25 minute video in your
Premiere Pro timeline but I have
different starts and stops and reshoots
and gaps in between my content well the
jump cut editor is going to cut out all
of the downtime and you can even tell it
by decibel Point how quickly you you
want to cut after that final word and so
YouTube editing sometimes almost has
like a hyper fast feel to it or if you
want a little bit more margin again
these are leveraged tools it's helping
you just go faster and of course after
you use the jump cut editor you need to
go in and maybe delete some parts that
you repeated yourself and review the
footage but everything about autopod is
about saving you time and helping you go
faster and so if you're an Adobe
Premiere user or you know somebody who
is or somebody on your team is no doubt
about it you should check out autopod
two things number one I've had too much
coffee today number two if you have not
seen our free master class yet you're
gonna love it if you're serious about
growing your YouTube channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class